sie ist eine heldin auf vier pfoten
labrador hündin luna erscheint pünktlich
um 10 uhr 30 zu ihrem blutspendetermin
in berlin zehlendorf
es geht hier schließlich um leben und
tod für flummi der 14 jährige afghane
war am donnerstag am teufelssee von
einem wildschwein angefallen worden
der berüchtigten laptop clown den
wildsau flummis hinterlauf wurde dabei
übel zerfleischt er erlitt massiven
blutverlust flummis hämatokritwert also
sein gesamt blutvolumen lag am
sonntagabend bei 19 statt der üblichen
36 ein wert unter 20 bedeutet
lebensgefahr
er ist ein bild aufruf bringt hoffnung
ich habe online mäßig über die bild
erfahren dass der hund hilfe braucht und
blut braucht und deshalb bin ich habe
ich mich mit der klinik auseinander
gesetzt und bin heute morgen um mit der
luna hierher gekommen
insgesamt 36 bild leser machten prompt
termine für die blutspende
bereits in der nacht von sonntag auf
montag stand um 2 uhr ein tierischer
spender samt besitzer vor der klinik
noch mal dank an die spender weil die
haben heute nacht war jemand da und hat
noch mal blut abgegeben also der hund
hat gut abgegeben ich bin auf jeden fall
richtig richtig dankbar weil dieses
direkt blut was wir jetzt von der frau
meine rente bekommen können ist
natürlich wesentlich wesentlich besser
14 bluttransfusionen doch noch immer
befindet sich afghane flummi in
lebensgefahr
nun das blut per direktübertragung ist
ein weiterer schritt auf dem weg der
besserung
trinken nicht vergessen zum
flüssigkeitsausgleich spenden von hunden
über 20 kilo sind nach wie vor
willkommen und lebenswichtig für flummi
dann jetzt möchte ich sprechen mit
flummis frauchen cathleen es mir nun
zugeschaltet und natürlich die
allererste frage wie geht es vor mir
gerade also im moment ich habe gerade
die nachricht bekommen flummi ist jetzt
stabil dank einer spende gestern
nochmals von einem jeep und inka das war
besonders beeindruckend weil das mädel
ist anderthalb stunden her gefahren ist
tierpflegerin
einem tierheim und hat nicht mal das
geld eigentlich dafür das war so
herzzerreißend und das war auch wieder
letzter letzten drücker weil der eigene
hierunter gebucht war für ihn der
konnten die spenden weil er war viel zu
klein der war anderthalb jahre und
durfte noch nicht spenden
und das war praktisch ein echtes glück
bis jetzt stabil der hat ein hämatokrit
wert von über 30 das ist sensationell
die klinik ist stolz wir sind stolz und
vor allen dingen dass so viele spender
kam sensationell muss er jetzt sagen in
letzter zeit war es dann tatsächlich von
einer blutspende zur nächsten wie soll
es jetzt weitergehen brauchst promi
diese weiterhin regelmäßig oder kann er
jetzt schon wieder alleine sozusagen
ohne dass blut von anderen hunden
überleben
nein das kann er nicht ich hab ja wir
haben gerade die information bekommen
dass er jetzt weitestgehend stabil ist
und ansonsten ist er auch fieberfrei
aber wir haben immer noch die
möglichkeit dass die anderen hunde
standby sind mit den spenden falls noch
was ist und er jetzt weiter
dann geht es gut aber wir müssen gucken
dass er auch stabil bleibt und nicht
absinkt kann man jetzt eigentlich jemand
für diese für dieses unglück für diesen
vorfall verantwortlich gemacht werden
natürlich das wichtigste ist dass es
flogen jetzt gut geht aber es werden
auch sehr hohe tierarztkosten auf sie
anfangen können sie jemanden dafür
verantwortlich machen
das ist der punkt der ja eigentlich noch
zu klären ist weil ich würde man davon
ausgehen also das ist die abteilung ab
zwischen 1000 und 2000 euro locker würde
mich so irgendwie so in dem dreh wird
sich das schon rum pendeln und jetzt
muss man natürlich mal gucken weil
juristisch betrachtet ist amtierende
sache und eine sache hat eine sache
verletzt und was eigentlich der
bundesrepublik gehört ich weiß nicht wie
das geregelt ist man muss einfach mal
schauen ob da jemand im grunde genommen
verantwortlich gemacht werden kann dass
es mich persönlich stört ist dass wir
haben in der presse richtig richtig oft
aufmerksam darauf gemacht auch von
seiten des dlrg aus dass das eine gefahr
darstellt und die haben die leute weiter
da baden lassen also entweder hätte a
oder b
wie beckham muss aber da ist einfach
sagen einfach vom senat seite nichts
passiert und das ist eigentlich das
traurige an der ganzen angelegenheit